you guys have been together almost three
years now do is she the one you see
marriage in the future I mean absolutely
this is something that every couple
should do that's the whole point of a
relationship we're a family
Sam Ascari gettin candid about his
relationship with Britney Spears have
you families met yes yeah absolutely
and how's your relationship with the
kids it's absolutely amazing I made it
to paradise and you know Brittany's
Instagram post turns out Sam's the one
holding the camera guess what the
housekeeper's just into my closet paul
weitz she's the producer director I'm
the actor we're just gonna work out and
she does you know I let that stuff to be
you know she's the woman and she needs
to she needs to do that stuff but she
loves you know dancing working out and
really putting it cute content she's
been an artist forever so you know
Brittany and Sam first met on the set of
her slumber party music video
[Music]
so what was it like when you got the gig
of a lifetime really and you got the
call you're gonna be Britney's love
interest radio so actually that wasn't
my first music video that was no second
first one was work from home from fifth
harmony okay so it was fun you know I
got a lot of attention from fifth
harmony so I knew what I was stepping
into I said fifth harmony was just
coming out as a as a little group and
now Britney Spears the Princess of Pop
is calling me wanting me to be the play
the love interest of the movie I said
why not let me give it a shot
and so did you have to audition like how
does that work for videos I did not have
to audition the direct book honey
it was a direct book a good friend of
mine was working on the music video at
the time okay they told the casting
director he should cast this guy yeah
and then they send my pictures to my
girlfriend and she picked it she said I
wanted this guy and then so that's
that's how it was and so what a trip
because then five months later you get
another call and it's not to be in the
video it's let's go eat some sushi right
absolutely which is your mind just
explode real life I mean at the music
video we connected we talked like you
know she said before we talked on the
music video we talked about what what do
you like to eat sushi here and there and
then you know text messages and next
thing you know they just like a normal
couple and now a Sam is ready for more
acting what kind of roles are you
getting called in for like I imagine you
sort of as like the next generation of
the rock like where it's like handsome
but like soft muscles like oh kill the
aliens but also make you fall in love
with me that's exactly what we're going
for
absolutely I'm getting called to Disney
like kids shows and and kids movies all
the time and at the same time the killer
of the entire movie